[Música]
o que é isso é b do alipay em que é isso
aí que já ouvi essa música podia alencar
na descrição do vídeo tá e aí galera que
assistiu ao canal todo bom vocês comigo
está sensacional é terça estou muito
feliz porque esse é o de fazer vídeo no
youtube eu consigo fazer pessoa de
qualquer lugar do mundo sorri isso é
mais mesmo que você aqui de são paulo
assistindo é do piauí está assistindo
também a galera da europa está
assistindo também no próximo mês sem
fazer show na europa para que massa
bichos é muito show e muito brasileiro
que vai embora para tentar a vida e ter
essa vontade essa carência de cor
brasileira em torno de 9 novembro times
perdão é de novembro em milão na itália
11 9 abril juric 12 de novembro em
londres 13 de novembro em paris na
frança e 14 de novembro em dublin na
irlanda então você que mora em alguma
dessas cidades em que é brasileiro
você que mora aqui tem algum amigo que
mora lá algum parente já morte isso aqui
pra ele que eu vou estar lá em ingressos
no meu site www esposas br1 junto ou te
dar sim segundo agora você clicar em
gosto nesse vídeo só para esquecer taher
ano e que gostei foi o cara o mundo
mudou as coisas mudaram eu sou suspeito
para falar porque na verdade não gosta
de gente vazia no meu tempo era assim
não é porque as coisas têm que mudar
mesmo com tempo da água tem coisa que
muda e assusta a gente eu tive infância
lá em santa luz do piauí equipe me a
minha infância sempre minha voz e foi
pobre existe uma grande diferença entre
a avó do rico e avó do pobre mesmo o
nome o nome do rapaz a atenção que é
muito diferente eu fui na casa meu dia
10 que é rico não dá voto 43 e no recall
andré o essencial para você eu não
confio no bolo do voz chamado andré eu
não confio vó que chama andré a certeza
faz aqueles bolo massa pronta sabe só
aqui e bota vod verdade chamam de velha
casa neide amélia por marli avó do caixa
andré o vovô do kashima pablo isso não é
nome de vôo meu deus é um cara chamado
pablo não sabe plantar não sabe que a
lei de vaca pablo olha lá vem o pablo
com leite da vaca um cola o nome de voto
o agripino bastian bagé nem mesmo
matusalém onu pelo menos uma pessoa no
forte com o nome pela manhã a tipóia e
tâmara e tal max fala o nome itamar eu
já imagino a cara com espingarda nas
costas já é o casal vota e não convocará
andré sá foi almoço não caia andré neide
neide no ranking mombolo na vida der
meyde que o nome sustenta meio chega na
casa da avó dele avó de isabella blow
caminhando abraçando chamando pelo nome
tudo mil deus como time grande o meu
bebê é que como você tá grande meu filho
disse uma vez quando era criança de bebê
lo do país que tinha um cabelinho
precinho assim da oit para martinho
bebelu o ibio tegami um filme meu filme
fomos primeiro escalão federal n chic
d'água estudando fiquei indignado por
ver meu deus vovó que sabe o nome do
neto e desconfiada essa volta ea avó do
rico sabe o nome do meta ela sabe o nome
do neto a vovó do pó batem tanto neto
mas tanto é tanto neto tataranetos kanxa
neto ela tem tanque para acertar o mundo
né tá meu filho ela fala o nome tanto
filho sou eu pensava que meu nome era
diabo que a vovó toda vez que ela me
chamava chamavam do neto disse no final
jogava oitava e no ataque em adén e
galván a a bicho menino menina o diabo
eu identifico de rita e porcelana né os
dentes todos naturais ruins mas a minha
voz é rica e ainda não tem todos os
dentes e logo se deitado mais usa colega
coréia fita adesiva propaganda que
houvesse abraça tudo sorrindo feliz a
avó do pobre você pode prestar atenção
que a voz do povo é a chapa solta a
deputado do pobre é solto ela brinca com
dente e aumentar conversando comigo nada
faço aqui ó
opa a roupa todo dia um fã
ari lasha ele brinca com dentro dele a
avó rita lado do meu amigo perguntando
se ela tinha assistir todas as cepas de
game of thrones olha se isto gatti assim
sensacional aquele ato que faz um não eu
acho sensacional aquele cara que ele
caiu de joelhos série inteira gabbana o
trabalho profissional senhora gosto
muito daquela série entendeu aquele é
não acho charme falar a verdade
compreendam cadeirinha de bebê para
passear com ele está minando sensacional
a velha assistindo sério fiquei meu deu
essa diferença do rio favor do pólo
naval do rio até netflix já sabe mexer
num controle onde podes assistir um
programa é minha voz existia tv
aparecida e meu vou assistir o canal do
boi avó do pobre a sister vai aparecer
porque gosta não é porque da liga
tradição já a tv aparecida é golpe aqui
quem fala com a nokia a assistir à missa
que tal pai cantando o que é que eu sou
sei jesus nada na oc2 a assistir o canal
do boi que eu acho que decorou um número
que apertar e do canal do boi ele e
dormir eu sei se a voz do cara fazia eu
vou dormir eu escutava do chamado para
uma bolha oral menor e nós aproveitamos
lembra 300 quilos duzentos e cinqüenta
50 76 303 sentou se ao meu vôo eu
desligava televisão
andré não rodei desenvolve ou de elevado
risco maior de andréia eu vou na cozinha
um gelágua tomando água de gelágua na
caça de foca a casa da minha avó e três
portas e pegava com um gancho haiti um
negócio e enfiava assim puxava água boa
tarde outro copa costuma tomar água
gelada de geladeira vovó quero água no
pátio eu queria água gelada vontade não
pode ficar menor bem rádio bebida na
casa do rico a memória tinham base onde
whisky é a regra
rodei ba abriu frente a hynix vovô do
pobre não vou nem falar em derrota que o
arranque rápido a atacar google de
rabbani e uísque que mandam escárnio
rotina no link tcheco ouviu o leite
kashaya tea por um caranguejo desse
tamanho do lixo fica a minha nossa
senhora como foi botar os caranguejos
está cotado para receber que ninguém
deve foram alimentando a limitar até
ficar grande morretes é outro lithium
cajuda época a minha nossa como foi que
esse caso cresceu dentro desse negócio
meu deus as vazias da avó do ric ao
quintal é com tampas giratório sai de
seu alimento fique guardado dure mais
sem conservantes vasilha de holly pobre
minha avó sabia nem falar com a palestra
já sob a roupa social que voltem os
negócios a senhora e folha foi uma coisa
boa tanto tem uma tapa na minha frente e
eu estava a chegar minha caminha receita
seria referente a pagar só pode ser a 8
papel embora de menino na minha em
guardar falei para o lenny não tão não
transmitir que ficava cantando meu
terreiro eu gosto faz buraco que já não
se pode fazer é fácil agora cuidar
empurra pra cada hóquei voltar a ver
qual é feita a chega onde choveu na onu
eu fiquei tão carrega a marca do [__]
não importa que tipo de voz e tem
portanto quem te ama da gente é muito
legal se você gostou esse vídeo não
esquece
clique em gostei aqui por favor você tá
pelo celular pelo computador que gostei
e inscreve no canal nunca perder vídeo
novo volta no facebook onde tem vídeo
novo vod rico pode pobre curti la plata
que veio pelo facebook há muito é só
você interagir com o facebook continuar
mudando pra você também quem gostei aqui
no youtube youtube continua a mandar
você você quer do twitter trt trt roda
itsm não sabe que portais é o que
cheguei cansado de que 20 mil r t no dia
do vídeo da dormiu rt fonseca no twitter
disse que viu pelo instagram arrastando
vai lá no fim de curtir a foto de
divulgação o popular vídeo novo total
muito obrigado a assistir os vídeos aqui
é nóis valeu e brinca